The "Venom" sequel unleashes a lot of carnage, but
it doesn't have answers for everything you want to
know. Will Anne ever dump Dr. Dan and get with a
hero instead of a zero? Will Venom finally meet
Spider-Man? These are the biggest unanswered
questions in "Venom: Let There Be Carnage."
In a key scene of the "Venom" sequel, Eddie
Brock goes to visit Cletus Kasady in San Quentin.
At first trying to play things cool, Eddie
finally loses it when the convicted serial
killer begins comparing himself to Eddie.
Kasady killed multiple members of his family;
Eddie, he claims, killed a
family member when he was born.
In the comics, Eddie's mother did indeed die
from complications during childbirth — a tragedy
compounded when his father, Carl Brock, came to
treat the child with an icy, angry detachment.
Much of what Eddie became — athlete, star student,
journalist — was in a desperate attempt
to gain his father's approval and warmth.
In actuality, Brock is somewhat in
the neighborhood of Cletus Kasady.
While that first death may not have been
his doing, an older Brock got drunk in the
comics once and accidentally struck and killed a
child with his father's car. In that storyline,
Eddie wanted to turn himself in and face
the music, but his dad talked him out of it.
Whichever Eddie Brock storylines are making their
way to the silver screen, this much is certain:
Eddie has some serious guilt on his shoulders.
Kasady knows exactly which buttons to push,
and when Eddie gets mad, Venom wants
to help his buddy out. But ultimately,
this fit of rage only leads to Kasady taking in
the symbiote, causing more death and destruction.
"Is Venom gay?" Those are three words you most
likely didn't think you'd be asking yourself on
the way out of the theater, but it's a very real
question that the movie definitely brings up.
"Venom: Let There Be Carnage" has a scene where
the symbiote, on the rebound after a bad breakup
with Eddie, finds himself at a San Francisco
rave. After turning down the advances of a woman,
the alien gets up on stage and delivers
a rant that includes the declaration:
"I am out of the Eddie closet."
Speaking about the movie's credited writers,
Kelly Marcel and Tom Hardy, Serkis implied
that the scene very much means what you think
it means. He shared in an interview with Uproxx,
"Tom and Kelly were always about
Venom coming out and going to a
party that was a very sort of an
LGBTQIA kind of festival, really,
I'd call it. So, this is his coming out party
basically. This is Venom's coming-out party."
We already know that Venom has a
certain degree of gender fluidity.
The symbiote inhabits genders indiscriminately,
and although Venom has come to appreciate Eddie
Brock (even at one point declaring love for him),
Venom also seems to enjoy inhabiting old
Mrs. Chen's body and having Anne get flirty.
The bottom line? By the end of the film,
Venom seems happy and comfortable
with himself. That's all that matters.
"You bet your ass."
"Venom: Let There Be Carnage" doesn't give viewers
any idea where Shriek, aka Frances Barrison,
got her powers. Specifically, we're talking about
her ability to emit an eardrum-piercing scream
that can kill humans and temporarily disorient
sound-sensitive symbiotes like Venom and Carnage.
Instead, the audience meets Frances
in a cell at St. Estes Reform School
adjacent to Cletus Kasady, who
makes her a paper promise ring
before she is whisked off to her new
home at Ravencroft mental institution.
Much of this is because, in a series
where everyone else seems to be gaining
powers via symbiotes, Shriek's talents are
derived from her status as what has been a
dirty word for movies based on Marvel
Comics not called "X-Men": "mutant."
Back around the turn of the century, as Marvel
sold rights to various properties to studios,
only 20th Century Fox secured the rights to
the mutant corner of the Marvel universe,
which it famously used for its
own series of "X-Men" movies.
Now, things appear to be on
the path to mutants finally
joining the MCU — but since the "Venom"
films are technically Sony productions
in Sony's own Universe of Marvel Characters,
you can see where things get muddled.
In the original Marvel comics, Shriek had a
horrific upbringing that involved physical abuse,
body-shaming, drug use, and even being
shot in the head by a police officer.
All this led to the awakening
of her latent mutant abilities,
which include sound manipulation, levitation,
and even some psychic powers and mind control.
Based on the explosive end credits
scene of this "Venom" movie,
it's not likely we'll get answers about
Shriek's mutant origins any time soon.
The first time Venom sees Carnage in the
flesh, the black symbiote recedes back
into Eddie Brock's body like he's a frightened
Hulk who just saw Thanos walk into the club.
"Oh, shit!"
"Whoa, where are you going?"
"That is a red one!"
"You need to come out right now."
"ROAAAAAR"
As comic fans know, many symbiote
species have their own colors,
with Venom being black, Scream colored yellow,
Sleeper being green, and so on. The reason why
Carnage is red is because it entered Cletus
through his bloodstream. In the comics, Eddie
was in a prison cell with Cletus when Venom's
spawn accessed Kasady through a cut in his hand.
In the movie, a somewhat similar event occurs,
even if it gets tweaked a bit. Although Brock
and Kasady aren't in a cell together, the
serial killer manages to bite into Eddie,
after which he remarks upon the unique
composition of Eddie's inner workings.
"I have tasted blood before, and that is not it."
Whatever "it" is, it is compounded when
the state tries to put Cletus Kasady to
death via lethal injection. Carnage uses
the opportunity to finally seize Kasady,
breaking free from the restraints
and beginning his killing spree.
So, why is Venom so afraid of a
"red one"? Well, for starters,
anyone can see that Carnage is clearly bigger
and seems to have more weapons at the ready.
It's also generally accepted that each spawn of
a symbiote is stronger than the one before it,
so Venom knows right off the
bat that he's at a disadvantage.
Also, it never helps when the
symbiote you're about to go up
against has chosen a host who just so
happens to be a ruthless serial killer.
But the significance of him being red, and
that being scarier? That's unexplained.
Who knows? Maybe Venom just read
the comic books when he was a kid,
and knows with one glance that
he's in for maximum carnage.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.